yo so
something that happened to you recently
that i feel like uh has happened to
someone who i'm close with actually one
of the artists that i manage um
is an extra year has accused you of some
[ __ ] that you didn't do
uh i thought you addressed it very
transparently on your project in a dope
way
um
what is that like to go through because
it's almost in 2022
if a girl could accuses you of something
it's almost impossible for you to defend
yourself because when it hits the
internet
i feel like and i i mean obviously this
is just from what i've experienced and
seen
there's really nothing that the guy can
say
that is like
that can really like
i guess maybe sway people to not believe
the female if that makes sense and it
kind of puts us all in a really weird
world where like anyone can say anything
about you and it's on you
to prove that it's [ __ ] what was
that like to go through man
it was terrible bro like it's um
it brings you you go through a lot of
stuff mentally and i realize that people
really don't know what that's like you
know to be that popular and to be
going through something like that you
know
so
it is when you're in it is bad you know
it's bad for your mentals for your
psyche and you really have to like
you have to keep your mind you know you
have to keep your head and that's the
hardest part is like
keeping keeping your brain through all
the [ __ ] that's happening around you
and like
moving forward and not backward you know
so yeah it was it like uh did you ever
did you feel helpless at all
hell yeah you know you feel it feels
like
it feels like damn this person that i
spent all this time with you know
a year and a half
you know it's like
you know everybody's been in a
relationship where
you have ups and you have downs right
and
but you have those really good times and
you share everything with this person
and you you know you're sitting down
watching stupid shows and all this stuff
for this so for somebody
to you know get angry one day
and try to ruin your life because so for
somebody else somebody to get angry at
you and then
because you don't you know want to be in
a relationship or because whatever
it's like and do that it's just like
it's it's mind-boggling you know yeah
it's crazy because kind of how you
describe the situation on your record
was kind of like very similar to what my
boy went through
and
it's like it's just it can be defeating
man because like i like it it's just
like what the [ __ ] like i feel like
people should really there should be
some sort of law that gets passed or if
you do some [ __ ] like that like you're
going to jail for as long as whatever
the [ __ ] you accuse someone of doing to
you because you could literally ruin
someone's life
because people don't even think
about the context or well what if she's
full of [ __ ] that's the thing
they don't even think it don't matter
they already made their mind up yeah i
mean but it also just so it
but that's the thing too man one thing
that i asked for before that whole thing
happened was for like
more confidence and more like clarity of
mind and everything and to really have
control over myself and my my mind and
like what's going on and that situation
kind of forced me
to to be one with myself you know what i
mean
so like
it really all of this [ __ ] that's
happening is [ __ ] you know what i
mean social media this that third like
people are so it made me realize that
people are really like dumb you know
what i mean like they're dumb but it's
not their fault you know it's they're
just flowing with the algorithm
they're going with their they're
designed to do this you know what i mean
it's like this thing is designed to take
control of your mind so like you believe
whatever you see you know
like it's like the despite of him you
like spiderman of course of course so
you watch the new spider-man and the
other where it's just like the guy oh
you mysterio the mysterious where he
made everyone believe yeah he's like
they'll believe anything nowadays
they'll believe anything and and the
thing is
that's the thing about the internet it
doesn't they don't these people don't
know me you know these people have never
had a conversation with me uh
so it's just like you start to think how
could this person actually have an
opinion about me you know and and even
did that incident aside just in general
yeah in general just like and the stuff
that people say on the internet like the
cruel crazy crazy and they would
literally never say it to your face so
you know what it is it kind of just like
put me in a place where i was forced
to like
step the [ __ ] up into
my manhood into like really the power of
my mind and just like and really so
every day
i i capture that more you know what i
mean so yeah put you in that secret like
almost like like feaster famine type
mentality where it's like
because if you let it that [ __ ] could
just
knock you off your rocker and you never
recover because
you have people who probably never heard
your music don't know you for from [ __ ]
commenting about you trying to get you
canceled it's it's a wild it's
definitely a wild situation i can only
imagine to be in it did you notice
people
uh start acting a little different i
tell you
everybody you know everybody
what
crazy and that's another battle you know
people around you acting different
people that know you
acting different you know people that
know you you know what i mean i like are
like close with you not everybody
obviously you have your day ones that
right right right rock with you and who
know you and be like yo there's some
[ __ ] whatever but
you know that's that's another battle
you know where you you have to even you
have to
get closer and closer to yourself you
have to accept certain things about
certain people and there's some people
that take advantage of the situation and
it's like oh now you're in this
situation oh now i'm gonna use it to do
this you know what i mean
it's like
it's it's a crazy it's a crazy situation
to be in but you know what like
when you keep your mind through some
[ __ ] like that
you end up way stronger you know what i
mean and your circle ends up way tighter
and the people that rock with you you
know they really [ __ ] with you you know
what i mean and you can like see like oh
i mean it almost kind of is like a
blessing in disguise in the sense that
like those people you're talking about
you know you they kind of expose
themselves in that in that time where
you could be like oh no i
when things got like this you behave
this way or you try to take advantage of
a certain type of situation and
you just cut them out
that's what it is and that's that's that
it's easy like that you know